It seems we you're bound to repeat history
and what his old becomes new again.
Why is it that we can't seem to
find equilibrium within a society?
Ideas begin with good intentions,
but lead towards the extreme.
Yeah.
Well,
the reason that we can't find equilibrium
is because the environment that we
live in isn't an equilibrium.
And so I,
I kind of imagine it this way.
It's like we're,
we're traversing the back of a giant,
this is obviously a symbolic reference
of the giant serpent and it's,
and it weaves back and forth and you
don't know at any moment which way it's
going to curve and turn.
And so sometimes it turns to the right
and sometimes it turns to the left.
And what that means politically is that
sometime we have to turn to the right
and sometimes we have to turn to the left.
And we don't know exactly when those,
um,
what new call,
we don't know exactly how to time that.
And so what we all have to do is keep
our eyes open and tell the truth and
discuss things with each other that are,
especially with people who have political
beliefs that are different than us,
so that we can ensure that we haven't
tilted too far one way or the other.
And that's why I'm an advocate of free
speech or one of the many reasons I'm an
advocate of free speech is because it's
the continual dialogue between people of
different temperamental types that keeps
us oriented as close as we can come to
the center of the serpents back.
And so there is no permanent equilibrium.
There's only the equilibrium that's
produced by continual negotiation and a
democracy is a formalized negotiation.
And so,
um,
and,
and it's free speech that
keeps it healthy and alive.
So,
um,
there's no permanent equivalent
equilibrium state except death,
you know,
and,
and it's always negotiation
in relationships too.
Like if you have an intimate relationship
or a familial relationship or even a
friendship,
there's no final equilibrium state.
You have to communicate
with each other honestly,
all the time,
and keep the relationship moving to adjust
the environment that the relationship
is operating in.
That's how it stays alive.
And in an intimate,
longterm,
intimate relationship,
like a marriage,
it's a continual,
uh,
it takes continual effort.
Uh,
I mean,
it's worthwhile effort and,
and that,
but you have to be conscious and awake
to keep your relationship alive and you
have to be communicating all the time.
Well,
maybe not all the time because
you can over communicate to,
but,
um,
so,
well,
so that's why we can't reach a
state of permanent equilibrium.